welcome to this video playing Alex
german player but haven't played him for
quite a while let's see I don't really
know what is playing ok though the chip
and ankle okay well this is a very
simplistic way to do it night to h5 here
oh now I cannot really remember the
exact theory funny okay chip g3 now on
this should be two looks very strange so
I probably should do that at least the
knight on f6 is not exactly helping with
playing a five but Jim he might still be
able to do it may be here five i wonder
if-if f4 is still a move I mean it looks
strategically it looks looks
questionable because of the dark squares
but if he go gets in if I if it's also
not great so let's do that
ok
I'm a bit worried about the week dark
squares like g3 III and so on but at the
moment it's not clear how he can maybe
exploit them you can try to Castle long
and I want to prepare 95-year now I
think I should be okay you won't be able
to do something right now if I've never
really possible just castling long
hmm not sure way is going with 97 I mean
you never play you five now maybe some
some drastic technical solution here
like if I've anyway I don't think so
hmm so anyway what am i doing maybe the
Queen over it's not really doing
anything on a form let me try to reroute
it I wonder if if you form is an idea
like this and II 45 yeah maybe difficult
to find a way forward to anyway maybe
should have prevented root G to what I
try to play quickly now
check yeah I have to have to do this
advanced absolutely no arguing I don't
think I'm okay here I mean age 5 that
Bishop h6 check I don't know if this
helped him I mean pancakes I take age
five I guess maybe I have something
better like f6 yeah this is not not
clear if I go a form and I'm trying to
trap this
hmm
not clear this is also not bad the point
is that if he takes Bishop takes I have
23 also as an additional idea when the
e6 point is simply more dangerous than
the age part I think the way the pieces
are coordinated at the moment so queen
bee three just asking this Bishop wed
and tends to go and this question to the
rook is pretty pretty annoying it has
absolutely no square so he's six on a
double attack double attack I guess
black resides them I don't know this was
a not good prolly on move like move 10
or 12 I don't know this is it looked it
looked a bit shaky this is kind of
business but he simply didn't didn't
didn't get anywhere here I don't know
what he should have done maybe it's not
bad I mean and then to this is
definitely quite okay but I think he
lost lots of time with moves that really
didn't help like 97 I mean what is this
doing he will never play e5 yeah and now
I'm pushing him this is just good for
white check this is this is a mistake it
loses time and dismiss places the bishop
yeah somehow this just went downhill for
black rather quickly surprisingly
quickly I didn't expect that to happen
Quincy 3 also good yeah i think what i
did should preserve an oops no haha yeah
here i blundered oh wow wow how that
would have been a cold shower i am from
this completely dominating position i
blundered this but he didn't see it i
have to have to play this and just go
from there wow I'm glad that he didn't
see that it would have been very
frustrating yeah no I'm okay again just
trapping all the pieces here Jeb we had
game I only allowed this Bishop takes
the fourth thing but he didn't go for it
thankfully okay well thanks for watching